[Musique]
yo maman
désolé dr maman comment pensez-vous que cette
année va se passer pour ces nouveaux étudiants
je suis excité tu es excité pour le premier
jour d'école
pourquoi tout le monde est si riche es-tu prêt
pour ma fête samedi soir j'ai dj
le bébé de khaled
pour te faire une playlist c'est bon timeout
ce qui se passe avec ces
enfants présents sera le gouverneur de
californie
max papa tu es magnifique et tes cheveux sont en
feu mon père vient aussi je me fiche
de ton père spencer
je m'en soucie juste  zach et kelly
nous voulons tous que ces nouveaux enfants se sentent les
bienvenus voyons ce qui se passe
pouvons-nous parler est-ce que tu viens de t'asseoir en arrière
sur une chaise wow je n'ai jamais vu personne faire
ça dans la vraie vie
ça ne marchera pas à moins que nous apprenions à les
connaître  vous savez seulement comment bayside
fonctionne pour des enfants comme vous
enfants chauds enfant privilégié enfants privilégiés
bayside à l'endroit où je me suis finalement senti comme si
j'appartenais cet endroit est magique
[ __ ] j'aime la magie hey max en fait j'ai
commandé du fromage sur le
mien regarde dans ta
poche  jamais st  op étant bizarre
un un deux trois
l'ancien gang à nouveau ensemble
[Musique
] veux-tu aller dîner avec moi arrête d'
écouter nous ne sommes pas nous sommes le
groupe a cappella de Bayside
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ah Bayside
l'homme  entraîneur quand je serai grand, je veux
être comme toi un adulte célibataire sans enfant
qui fait la fête avec des enfants